[Music]
hello everyone
i'm pleased to have as a guest today mr
michael melis
an author columnist and media
personality
he was the subject of the graphic novel
ego and hubris
by the late harvey picard of american
splendor fame
he is the author of dear reader the
unauthorized autobiography of kim
jong-il
2014 as well as the new
write 2019 a book that i've been reading
deeply this week that was reminiscent to
me of the new journalism
anthropology of tom wolf
he's the co-author of seven additional
books including made in america
the new york times best-selling
autobiography of ufc
of hall ufc hall of famer matt hughes
concierge confidential with michael
fazio 2011
which was one of npr's top five
celebrity books of the year
and most recently 2006 black man
white house comedian comedian d
l hughley's satirical look at the obama
years
also an nyt bestseller he served as a
cultural and political commentator on
podcasts with joe rogan dave rubin
tim poole my daughter michaela peterson
twice and
has his own youtube channel and podcast
you're welcome
my producer put a note at the bottom of
this aisle
um uh autobiography michael is a
comedian with a harsh
and fast sense of humor he's a big fan
of yours but be prepared for a little
bit of crazy
i got that impression reading your book
but in the best possible way i would say
so let's talk about the new right if you
don't mind i'd like to dive right into
that so
i said in the intro that it was
reminiscent to me of
the new journalism of the 1960s when i
first read
the electric kool-aid acid test which i
would recommend to everyone as a
brilliant journalistic anthropological
investigation into what became the
psychedelic culture in the early 1960s
it's a brilliant book
um and i got the sense in that in the
new right
you were doing much of the same thing
for whatever it was that was happening
from the time
of maybe 2013 to 2016 something like
that something that actually seems like
history already
interestingly enough and you talk about
from an insider's perspective in some
sense because you were an insider and an
outsider at the same time in these
groups but you talk a lot about
4chan and memes and
all these subcultures that exist online
that are
uh major forces and social domains in
their own right
but that are if not ignored
completely by the mainstream media so to
speak
consistently misunderstood and so
but but then by the same so i'd like to
ask you about that uh
we could start with 4chan maybe and
and maybe you could walk us through
first what it is and then what it was
and then what it is now if it's anything
because i did get the sense as well that
this happened already something else is
happening now and i don't know what it
is but
whatever it was you were writing about
that's five years ago which is a long
time in internet terms
sure uh i think right now first of all
discussing 4chan publicly
in context like this in some kind of
studious or serious context
violates the ethos of 4chan one of the
big rules about 4chan is
you know normies get out re so by
talking about it or
automatically i'm kind of positing
myself as someone who's an outsider i'm
not
you know on 4chan all the time but 4chan
is kind of emblematic of a broader
section of the internet which was driven
wasn't literally only 4chan but was
driven by
irreverency was driven by this idea of
that which is presented to us with
earnestness
should not be taken at face value that
this earnestness is
often used as a cudgel and as a
mechanism of affecting uh social control
uh certainly you've been the subject of
many memes i'm sure you're you're
familiar with yes
but yeah and the other the point that
they figured out there's an expression
that they say meme magic is real
the premise being you know the before
the new right the idea was
um you'd have these organizations
putting forth some kind of claim or idea
often absurd on its face and the
argument be like well that's not
accurate that's not fair
and the new approach was why are we
taking
this agit prop at face value
instead of mocking it clowning it and
basically rendering the tool um impotent
so that was kind of uh 4chan's pull
board
you had the donald subreddit on on
reddit
uh so there is this but you say that
it's misunderstood by the mainstream
press
i always use the term corporate press
because i don't really regard it as
mainstream but i don't know that it's
misunderstood so much as misrepresented
well i think it's probably both because
it's not easy
first of all there's an immense divide
between people who
don't use the internet as a social
mechanism or as their primary source of
information and people who do there's an
unbelievable divide and maybe maybe if
you're older than 50
you're in the world of 1970 and if
you're younger than 40 you're in the
world of 2010
and those are really different worlds i
mean you talk about
the corporate press and i've been
thinking a lot about
the the technological impact of youtube
and and podcasts so and this is why i'd
like to dig into the misunderstood
part first before we go to the
misrepresented part
what i see what i saw popping up in your
book continually was two things
happening in 4chan there's
there's a there's troublemaking that in
some sense is
there for its own sake and i'd like to
talk to you about that
there's there's a political uh there's
political movement
but then there's also this exploration
of what is actually a technological
revolution so
you think about um legacy media
so i've noticed that when i've gone to
tv stations and been interviewed by a
journalist
i'll have a discussion with the
journalist in the green room
and i'm talking to a person then but as
soon as the cameras go on
i'm not talking to a person anymore i'm
talking to someone who's an adept
mouthpiece for a massive corporate
organization
but but that was actually a necessity
because the bandwidth for television was
so expensive
that it wasn't possible to grant any
individual untrammeled access to it
and so it was inevitable that a
corporation was never going to allow
except in exceptional cases any
journalist to have what would truly be
an individual opinion and certainly
wasn't going to let them explore
ideas in real time too expensive too
risky
um but then now we're in this weird
situation and i the 4chan guys were
playing with this to some degree where
it isn't obvious that the corporate
media platforms have any advantage
whatsoever
over anyone who's technologically able i
mean the fact that we can have this
discussion for example so
there we have one go ahead i would say
they have one very big advantage which
you've seen yourself which is
the concept of legitimacy so your
previous book
the uh the new york times refused to
basically acknowledge it as being
printed america
so you can't say it's a new york times
bestseller even though
the number it's sold is just you know a
huge amount is hugely successful right
so uh the deer reader the book i did for
about north korea which we'll talk about
later i did that with kickstarter
as a result of that on amazon it looks
the same it's going to have a page
listing like another page listing
but the new york times uh you know all
these other elements they're in a
position
i got an hour on c-span's book tv so
that is changing in that regard
but it gives them an opportunity to
pretend that this book doesn't exist
so unless a book is being published by
certain um
outlets that have legitimacy basically
it's just like
i i don't know if you watched wrestling
growing up i certainly did the wwf when
i was a kid
there were rival organizations and they
literally acted as if these rival
organizations didn't exist and if a
wrestler came over from the nwa
to the wwf they acted like he was this
new discovery
that he had no history to him it was
very odd because all you had to do was
change the channel
and they're acting in certain other
mechanisms so that is a big advantage
because
if you go to talk to mom and you say
where'd you hear this i heard this on
cbs where did you hear this i heard this
on 4chan
it's it's very clear which one mom is
going to choose
no i i agree but but part of what the
4chan guys were doing by your own
account to some degree
was testing these new technological
platforms to see
how much power they actually had so
these
these trolling games that you described
so you describe trolling as something
that's
actually quite specific it's in its
intent when it isn't just being
say adolescent foolishness it's
something like
can we create a narrative and string
along
um legacy media types and some of that's
a joke but some of it's also a test is
like does this new technological
platform have enough power
to to bend and twist what what has been
the standard means of delivering the
cultural narrative for decades and the
answer to that frequently was yes
and increasingly the the legacy media
uh outlets are suffering from dela
legitimization they lose money they lose
their ability to fact check and
because they don't have this
technological advantage anymore they
have the remnants of their brand
it's something like that yeah and
there's also something there's a very
big
asymmetry between honesty and dishonesty
right if you and i are good friends and
i tell you one major lie
well that's one statement out of tens of
thousands that one statement is still
going to do
much more damage than one honest
statement because i've lost
uh there's an amount of trust lost so
their brand
has been and they say this explicitly
cnn had ads not that long ago saying
this is an apple
we only report facts if you are if i'm
coming at you and saying
that i am only reporting facts as soon
as i'm caught in one
misrepresentation even if it's innocent
which i don't think it is in most cases
right away uh there that just kind of
collapses the souffle
because i trusted you i relied on you
and now you're giving misinformation
but most importantly and this is where i
differ from more mainstream
conservatives who have
think they think things have become
corrupted you made mistakes i've made
mistakes everyone makes mistakes all the
time this is
going to be inevitable simply from a
lack of knowledge what
steps have you taken once these mistakes
have been made to
make amends and also put yourself in a
position that you won't make the same
mistake again
and if you see with corporate media
oftentimes they'll do things that are
disingenuous but let's give them benefit
doubt let's just say they were sloppy
but no one gets fired there's no mia
culpa like you know what
like a tylenol is a great counter
example back in the early 80s i believe
it was
tylenol got some was poisoning tylenol
bottles people i think were dying or at
the very least were getting very sick
so title had this huge ad campaign that
said this is the steps we've taken
you know you got the child proof calf
you got the seal you got the cotton
whatever it was
this is how you know that we are safe
you can rely
on tylenol you don't see that with cnn
or fox or abc whenever they do these
egregious things they just pretend that
they never happened all along
or say that this is some kind of you
know you can't listen to the conspiracy
theories on the internet
so this is why there's this kind of
another loss of trust
because there seems to be very little
effort to maintain and foster that
trusting relationship between the
channels and the audience
and make amends when things have gone
wrong
so um
let's let's i want to go i want to
continue with 4chan for a bit can you
walk me through exactly
like you you said that one of the
mistakes that cnn did made for example
and also hillary clinton's campaign was
treating 4chan like it was actually a
person
and and as if there was someone who
could represent it and speak
can you lay out what exactly what what
it
is and how it works and then maybe we
can talk about the meme culture that's
associated with it
sure so 4chan and there's others there's
a chan there's a reddit and other such
uh their message boards so basically
4chan i don't remember how many boards
they have some are completely innocuous
so fitness is their fitness and health
board
fa is their fashion board guys can ask
does this
do these pants look good on me you know
what what kind of hat will look good
with my hair
you know innocuous stuff paul pol is
their politics board
so basically it's anonymous and it's not
um i believe
after there's 15 pages and after there's
no updates on a thread
the threads vanish into the net they're
in the netherworld wherever you can't
see them anymore
uh impermanent correct you can identify
yourself with the flag if you want when
you
when you log in but it's there's no
usernames it's not like facebook
so basically you know the hillary
clinton campaign in in 2015 2016
were positing about these sites and like
how is it that this is allowed to happen
but it's not the kind of thing where
it's like facebook
and you call mark zuckerberg and he
banned certain users the users are
ephemeral
um you don't know who they are it's the
posts are ephemeral
you know they just vanish off the board
so this claim that
you know the the comparison i had i
believe in the book
was kind of the more al-qaeda it's very
decentralized you know you you can't
really take out one person and then
the whole thing falls apart other than
you having to take try to take out the
site
which they tried to do earlier this year
and in late 2020
um but it's an entirely different model
and i think
people who are have that bureaucratic
mindset people have that elitist in the
sense that you have this managerial
elite
running things they can't even conceive
of an organization or a location or a
website
which is decentralized and there's no
like uh um
you know big bad vampire to kill once
you take out this vampire well
i mean but that is part of what i well i
thought was in some sense
you're documenting something that's so
revolutionary that even the people using
it don't know how revolutionary it is
you know and so because we have these
massive communication
technologies now and they all have
slightly different rules
and just by tweaking the rules a tiny
bit you can create a whole new
organization like tick tock let's say
which has videos of a certain length and
at least to begin with almost no other
it's all of a sudden that's a huge
social network doing all sorts of things
that no one has ever done before so
the rules for 4chan are really crucially
important to understanding it so
it's anonymous decentralized and
evanescent
and that's something yeah and they have
no one the two rules are no child
pornography
and uh there if there's pornography it
has to be stick to the pornography board
but
so it's pretty much the wild west when
it comes to free speech
right and the fact that it's not uh
permanent also so it's anonymized
and impermanent which means you'd think
at least in part that that
it would encourage a lot more
risk-taking because one of the things
that would mitigate risk is
the fact that it could be attributed to
you but also that it would be permanent
yeah that i mean that's the comparison
of 4chan let's say twitter where you
know someone's old tweets will be there
at the very least they're going to be
archived somewhere
you're going to have a consistent
username uh so even if it's not jordan
peterson if you're just going to be like
jack smith 37
they'll be able to track jack smith 37's
posts over time
you can't really do that um on a site
like 4chan or or 8chan
but there's other sites like this i mean
what what
what they have figured out is you know
you know the corporate press might
decide for chance the devil for chance
the devil 4 chance the devil
you take down 4chan well they'll just go
to discord or they'll go to all these
other
sites so technology is what allows
people it's designed
in contemporary terms for people to
communicate so if you're going to kind
of
take out one location where they're
gathering and trying to communicate
it's going to take minutes uh to find a
new location
now if there's going to be a cost
because you have to get the word out
through other means about this is where
we all are now
but it's very very hard when people are
basically effectively teleporting right
if for me to go from one location to
another physically after getting a plane
a car or train whatever
but if you go to one website to another
it i have to type in a web address
so if you just ban one address it the
amount of effort it takes to shift to
another one
could not be more minimal so okay so
you documented put so no one's in charge
of this but something happens and and
it's a communication network and
and it attracts people who
what it attracts people who are
communicating in a like
man minded way across time why did it
become a
place that was dominated at least by
your observations by the thought that
was associated with the new right
why did it converge on that because
4chan historically has been a site for
great irreverence
so they had had campaigns to um
troll and by trolling let me say
specifically what i mean
trolling is it's not just you know you
know you have a twitter account and i
say at jordan peterson
you're a jerk f off that's not trolling
that's just being obnoxious
trolling i i i regard the first troll as
andy kaufman
the comedian where what by your
performance you're turning a third party
by exploiting their weaknesses
into an unwitting performer on their own
for example there was a great wrestler
uh to bring it back to wrestling called
the honky tonk man from the 80s and his
shtick was he was an elvis impersonator
right
and when they interviewed him he would
say oh no
elvis stole my act now elvis had been
dead for 15 years at that time it
makes no sense whatsoever but this would
get the audience really enraged and
they'd flip out
so when you are calmly causing someone
else to have an extreme reaction
and in this case and in good trolling
he's exploding
exploiting their innocence and they
better i mean they're taking what he's
saying at face value even though it's a
complete absurdity
and what follows suit you know on some
case can be put in their lap
so they used to what what 4chan would go
would be known for
is you know for example you had a
mountain dew
right and they had name the next flavor
of mountain dew it's just
a corporate mechanism i talked about
this in the book it's a corporate
mechanism to sell you know your sugary
soft drink
uh what name should we call it and they
basically got enough people together and
this is kind of like rent seeking right
if you have an organized
um goal seeking minority as opposed to a
different majority
that organized goal seeking minority is
going to be able to punch very much
above its weight
in terms of getting the achievements at
once how many people are caring about
this mountain dew pole
very very few other than the trolls so
they got the
number one result to be hitler did
nothing wrong right
now they're not nazis they're not they
don't think the holocaust is something
that is didn't happen or is bad they're
putting now
this mountain dew who's trying to use
this fun
to sell you this poisonous sugary
garbage now the corporation is in
position
are they going to follow through with
this poll or are they going to pull it
whatever they choose they have been
forced into making a choice that they
themselves
would not have wanted because you have
someone in a meeting trying to
hey this is gonna be fun for the kids
and they ended up pulling
uh the poll because they're like okay
the internet won so
to go from that and this kind of extreme
um distrust if not contempt for
corporate irreverence and corporate
humor and corporate fun
to have basically can i curse on this
you can do whatever you want
okay well not everything so to have uh
someone who was basically a [ __ ] poster
on twitter
running for president uh who was just
there in these debates insulting these
politicians
to their face in often very below the
belt terms
that was that ethos brought to life
because no one could have imagined
in decades that you would have a
presidential contender
who's looking at a sitting senator in
the face who's who's
doing well in the polls and telling that
senator
i've never made fun of your looks and
there's plenty of material there
believe me that much i can tell you you
know this is something that was
completely unprecedented and new
and we've been taught for decades um
that you know politics should be about
respect it's these are tough choices
these are people's lives
that's all very true but there's this
very new left
from the late 60s perspective idea that
uh these kind of powerful entities use
respect
and decorum and decency as a mechanism
to stifle dissent
and to basically make their victory a
feta complete
and if you kind of mess that up and
force them to show their hand
that these are not kind caring people
who care about your grandma and your
neighborhood
these are power hungry sociopaths who
will smile at your face and do whatever
they need to when the lights are off
that i think uh was something is very
useful in terms of exposing our politics
for what they are
so it's it struck me over the last
decade or so that the
alignment of comedic satire with
right-wing
philosophy or or political philosophy or
views was
something that was completely also
completely unprecedented
i thought well all of a sudden the right
wing are the jesters
or at least among the right wing are
these jesters and i really didn't know
what to make of that i mean you seem to
regard it in your book the new right you
you seem to regard it as um a
kind of right-wing anarchic rebellion
against
but it's a strange it's strange what
they're against because on the one hand
there's the corporate
voice let's say that characterizes the
media and on the other
hand there's the left-wing progressives
and you can't really put them in the
same
camp all that easily well hopefully we
will be putting them in the same camp
um but they are in the same camp because
one of my quotes is conservatism is
progressivism driving the speed limit
so much of conservatism buckley got his
start william f buckley who's the
i think the big villain of the book god
has started complaining how
terrible things are and how mistreated
he was at yale
the new right perspective isn't
complaining about how things are yale
it's let's say tanks let's send tanks to
harvard's
harvard yard and raise it to the ground
so these are two different approaches
and much of conservatism for decades
this besides being inherently humorless
uh which is a personality thing which is
perfectly fine if that's your thing
it has been about a reaction so the left
would have some
idea of the moment we need to do this
and that the right would just dig in
their heels
get dragged along and it's a ratchet
effect constantly moving us toward a
more and more progressive
society the national reviews slogan
was standing at thwart history yelling
stop and then at certain point people
realized
how about instead of yelling we actually
stop it how about we actually try to put
a wrench into these gears how about we
try to
you know metaphorically tar and feather
some of these people
instead of just complaining that it's
not fair let's be aggressive and let's
take the fight to them okay and you see
and now
you clearly see an analog between the
tricks that trump used let's say the
humorous tricks that he used and
and the manner in which he appealed to
the public and whatever was going on in
places like
4chan and on reddit and with memes as
well
and you spend a lot of time in your book
talking about pepe for example so
what what is it that you see as the
connection i mean
look i saw this t-shirt in florida last
year that i thought was really apropos
it said uh trump 2020 because [ __ ] you
twice
yeah and i thought yes there's something
about that that's really
uh interesting and i've i've talked to
my progressive friends about this a lot
and because i'm trying to figure out
exactly what's going on and
and being appalled at least to some
degree at the
shenanigans of of the democrats among
others especially the identity politics
types because yes look i'll tell you
what
what i see in re relationship to my
books for example
so hypothetically um
this is the standard legacy media
critique of my books
i would say is that i'm peddling
nonsense that if not trite is outright
dangerous and which is kind of a strange
combination
two nerdwells who are so far beneath
contempt that
any attempt to help them is to be met
with suspicion
and that's something that really really
uh
puzzles me because when i meet the
people that i'm communicating with
you know when i walk around or when i go
to my lectures
you know i see individuals because i
look at individuals i see individuals
who are
trying to get their houses in order who
are off
often in desperate straits and they come
up to me and tell me
you know some step they've taken towards
improvement
sort of shame-facedly and but also happy
about it and
you know i'm very happy that that's
happening and tell them that and that's
my experience but then i see
in in in the response to my hypothetical
audience which is a misrepresentation to
begin with
nothing a contempt that's so deep that
the contempt is even there for the
attempt to help
and then i think well you progressive
types at least in principle
you're all for the downtrodden but i
don't know what it is
maybe if they stay in their place and
act like they're supposed to
there's this contempt among the helping
class let's say for those they're
hypothetically helping that's so deep
that
and i think it i think it destroyed
hillary clinton's campaign that contempt
her comments about the basket of
deplorables and the
democrat abandonment of the of the
working class
and and trump tapped into that somehow
and
and you draw connections and so i'd like
you to elaborate on that a little bit if
you would
sure and i whenever i try to talk about
people i always try to steal me on their
arguments and present them in the most
strong
position possible when the left is at
its best it's as
you mentioned it is about concerning
about marginalized people people who are
forgotten
uh the far left you know historically
would
care about prisoners rights and how bad
it is that this prisoner is treated
for most people it's kind of like lock
em up throw away the key
and that's kind of a left-wing idea that
like this guy's been forgotten
let's make sure he has food he's not
being you know assaulted on a daily
basis things like that
so they understand also in other
contexts that when you have
a young males who have nothing to lose
who are completely marginalized
who are spat on and called every name in
the book in other contexts
whether the middle east in the inner
city they realized
you keep pushing someone at the bottom
and keep telling him you're nothing
you're
you deserve to have nothing that young
male is going at the very least trying
to get some kind of monaco respect
try to get some modicum of status and
this often has literally very violent
consequences
because if i have nothing to lose but i
can make a name for myself
or i could for five minutes have a sense
of power some people are going to do
that arithmetic
and it's a very very bad thing and this
is
broadly speaking oh everyone will do
that arithmetic virtually as
unfair equality multiplies unfair
inequality multiplies
that that just becomes more and more
likely that response
so to your point is so in other contexts
they understand this but now we're
talking about your audience right these
are young
uh men who aren't doing so hot and now
they're being told
you're they they don't have a girlfriend
they desperately want to have a
girlfriend
and now they're told you're a loser for
not having a girlfriend it's like
well i'm trying to get out of that
situation i'm not trying to be some kind
of
date rapist i'm not trying to be some
sexual predator i just want to be normal
i just want to have maslow's hierarchy
of needs met but because they have been
assigned to be you're supposed to be
here at the bottom you've had your turn
you're the whipping boy of the moment on
an individual level this is going to
have
very deleterious consequences and
because you are telling them
listen you don't have to be even if
you're going to be at the bottom you
could still be a better person tomorrow
than you are today
well now you're kind of going to their
house and rearranging their furniture
uh and messing up their schemes so of
course they're going to react in uh very
aggressive ways towards your teachings i
think
well it's funny too because that notion
of my audience is a caricature to begin
with you know but
i don't care about that in some sense
i'm interested that the caricaturing is
occurring it's like there's a reason for
it
why they're all male they're all angry
they're all white it's like no
that's not right um and even if they do
skew mail
that's at least in part a legacy
hangover from the fact that most of the
people who watch
youtuber are male um but anyways
nonetheless that's that's the
categorization but then there's the
emergence of that contempt and i think
well
that is driving just as you pointed out
there that
that that insistence upon the
despicableness of that status
is driving i could see that in the 4chan
right and the writing about 4chan that
you were doing
that's that there's a there's a testing
and a pushing back that's going on there
and some of it is clowning and some of
it is like pointless troublemaking as
far as i'm concerned but there's more
going on in there than that
and that's for sure so and then it
coalesces around these right
these more right-wing ideas which i also
find somewhat surprising and so what do
you make
what do you make of that exactly is it
because those ideas are the ones that
are most specifically forbidden or
and and and the satirical comic
rebellious types
just glom onto them for that or what do
you think it is i think you hit the nail
on the head it's that if you tell
someone who's got nothing going on and
you say you know if you push this button
right here it's going to have some
really hilarious consequences for some
people
who think they're better than you and
have no problem telling you to your face
they're better than you
a lot of people are going to push that
button especially when the results are
often
um hilarious so it is going to give them
that sense of power
and i don't know that they're making the
wrong choice um i i don't think it's
very useful
to tell someone who's not really being
particularly aggressive
uh that you know you suck and you're
terrible and that
you know what it is like i don't make
fun of people for being overweight like
i go after people for a lot of things
i don't go after people who are going
overweight i had a friend who passed
away because he had morbid obesity
another friend who had a gastric bypass
because when you make fun of someone
who's overweight you're making fun of
all your friends who are overweight you
know they're seeing it as well
and here's the thing that person knows
they're overweight
they know they're going to be treated
differently they know they're going to
be
you know looked down on and all these
other things they're painfully aware
and it's the same thing here if someone
is marginalized
and you're calling him a loser he knows
he's a loser
at that point it just becomes a bit of
cruelty and bullying and also
anytime you try to tell someone
especially in america or in the west at
least
to sit down and shut up it's like why
who are you
to tell me to sit down and shut up
because now you don't have the power to
tell me to sit down and shut up
you have that power in school you have
that power in the office maybe you had
that power
when there were three networks now that
there's infinite networks if you look at
the internet
you can't silence me so i am going to
talk and if i see that it's upsetting
you
and you hate me even though you don't
know me yeah it's gonna be a value for
me to upset you because i do think
you're a bad actor
i think is the mindset and i don't think
that mindset at all irrational
so let's dig into that a little bit i
mean i got memed like mad when i first
rose to whatever prominence i've risen
to or or notoriety or
whatever there were memes and i think
that's probably still the case there are
memes being generated
in in the hundreds like weekly it was
crazy
and i was watching them and i thought
if i behave myself
properly those won't get unbearably
cruel
okay i thought if i can take a joke
then they're going to tilt in a manner
that's more positive rather than more
negative because i could see that there
was a testing going on there
you know that these jokes were being
pushed at me and i suppose to some
degree pushed out whoever was listening
to me
that and had i responded negatively to
that in any um
i remember when i worked on working
class working crews you know that one of
the things that almost always happened
was that when someone knew
joined a crew there'd be a test period
where
you know various forms of insults and
and
would be hurled at them and it was an
attempt to see how they responded and if
they responded with good humor
and accepted their stupid nickname with
some good grace and
and could laugh about it maybe could say
something funny in return then
you know after a week or two if they did
their job then everybody accepted them
and the way
they went but if they got all uh uptight
about it
then it just got meaner and meaner until
they were driven off
and i could see that happening with the
memes and you know i was compared to
kermit the frog for example and that
sort of morphed into a peppy thing and
um i was watching that and and hopefully
was able to take a joke when one
emerged and at least one of the
consequences of that seemed to be that
it never got truly toxic and so i'm i'm
struggling with the morality of the
4chan approach you know because
there's a part of me that thinks jesus
christ don't you have anything better to
do
but there's also a part of me that
thinks well wait a second there's
something really complicated going on
here that has to do with the
redistribution of power
and also the acquisition of a voice by
people who are individuals and not part
of a corporate group let's say but who
have access to tremendous technological
power and they're serving the function
of gestures and they're serving the
function of comedians and
like i think comedians in particular are
the canaries in the coal mine for a free
culture
as soon as the comedians are threatened
you know
some things as soon as the comedians are
nervous you know something's up
because you should be allowed to make
fun the biggest meme of yours that i
use this meme of yours constantly on
twitter is the kathy newman meme
and one of those examples is you know
that famous interview you have people
don't know where
you were saying things that were pretty
straightforward or maybe people
disagreed with you
and she would just ask you a question
that seemed to be complete non-sequitur
to what you had just said and this kept
going on for the whole time
the the one that comes to mind is a
picture of you saying
i had bacon and eggs for breakfast and
her reply is so you're saying kill all
vegans
um so often times if someone if you have
something on twitter and some
responds with a non-sequitur reproach
you just reply with a picture of her
and people right away know oh so what
you're saying is it has nothing to do
what it is you're actually saying i
think what you're what you are saying to
be the opposite of cathy newman in this
context is accurate
in that a lot of powerful people are
there through inertia
are there through uh nepotism are there
through you know corporate means because
memes because they play the game if i'm
not part of the game
why should i be playing the game and
here's the other thing where i think
these people are uh heroes
is the thing that they're best at is
when it comes to the thing that is the
worst which is war
we are constantly uh proselytized in
corporate media
that war is great we need to have people
overseas we need to have more and more
more troops more whatever
if you have a president who is regarded
as contemptible
if you look at trump versus barack obama
it's a lot harder for that president who
isn't venerated
to send young men and women to die
because if there's a skepticism
about his pedestal that he's on right
away you really have to make sure you're
selling this war
uh or otherwise there's gonna be this
it's just easy to clown you because the
arguments used for these wars
are often so ridiculous on their face so
what was you what was the conclusion
that you've drawn
now it's been a couple of years since
you wrote um the new right
so and
what what what are your later thoughts
on and on
on boards such as 4chan and what's
happening in 4chan now
it doesn't seem like i think 4chan has
to some extent falling away as a
cultural force i mean they were
i mean they were trying to meme trump
into the presidency and that happened
successfully
in 2016. uh the donald which was the
board on reddit was banned
uh during the election i think they
respond as the donald duck win
uh and these other you know and again
with these decentralized things if you
try to figure out where everyone's going
you know then you're going to have
subgroups people define themselves by
opposition
not by unity so anyone who has any kind
of ideology
will tell you the people they argue with
the most are the ones who are basically
one degree of separation away from them
within that ideology
so i think right now there is kind of a
of what happens next now that there's a
biden presidency but
the focus has shifted and i think this
is extremely healthy for those of us who
value liberty
it has shifted from washington and this
has always been kind of the background
to corporate media and understanding
that nancy pelosi
and joe biden and mitch mcconnell and
ted cruz
will never despise you and will never
have as much contempt for you
as the editorial board the new york
times or the people at the new yorker uh
it's it's
they're much or let alone many academics
so having the trolling and the memes be
much more focused
on what manchester small block called so
why do you think that's why do you
think that's do you think that's true
and why do you think that's true because
that's quite a radical statement i would
say but i i think
it does speak to this t-shirt that i
mentioned earlier yeah you know so your
your sense what you just told me was
that
there is this elite contempt and to some
degree it was associated with the
political class but on
further analysis it's not the political
class
it's the chattering literary the
chattering educated literary and i
actually
happen to think that that's the case
that that's actually true
so why do you believe that
sure i'll give you a couple examples
first and the the arch villains and
i i'm not trying to troll you are the
university professors
that's where the poisoning really really
starts but let me give you an example to
demonstrate which is wagging the dog
whether it's because the ar
used to be the argument was about
washington andrew breitbart you know who
certainly falls into this new right kind
of context
made the quote about politics being
downstream of culture and the idea was
wait a minute if we're fighting in
washington
by that time it's already you know
fourth down and we're down how many
points it's it's
it's a the consequence of what led up to
this let's suppose i was a democratic
congresswoman or congressman and i
thought president trump was a
nazi klansman horrible hitler every name
in the book
at the same time i did not think that
there was any kind of collusion with
russia
or or any kind of something wrong with
that phone call maybe he's a jerk but i
certainly don't think he should be
impeached or moved from office
all my constituents have been hearing
for months
from the televangelists to the left don
lemon rachel maddow
trump russia trump russia trump russia
how could i
as a democratic congressman go back to
my constituents and say guys i agree
with you
this guy is the worst president in
history and he's a despicable human
being
but you don't impeach someone over this
this is you know ratcheting up and
nonsensical
as a congressperson i would not be in
the position
to make that claim and i think that is a
good demonstration
of who is in charge of whom there's a
clip online i'm sure people can find
where don
don lemon from cnn had john kasich on
former
uh i think uh house budget direct budget
committee chairman
uh governor of ohio he was a major
presidential candidate 2016
and he's yelling at him john john john
and you're sitting there and it's like
it's very clear who regards themselves
as the authority
and who regards them who is regarded as
the subject in that relationship
so okay so what if i said um maybe we
should just stop caring about that too
because the technological playing field
for communication has been leveled so
drastically that
the new york times and the legacy media
types are basically dead in the water
and that's just going to play out
like inevitably over the next three or
four years and i i was
let me give you just a quick example one
yes
they were if they were dead in the water
the lockdowns couldn't have happened
i don't i don't think they're dead in
the water now but i think the writing's
on the wall
i agree that's why i'm i'm going to
write a book called the white pill
because i'm so optimistic i think
they're they're
borrowed time then we can also talk
about what happens next and we can talk
about the difference between podcasts
and legacy media too
which i think are i'm trying to think
through right now and because
i think the youtube podcast long-form
uh uh structure is very is revolutionary
in all sorts of ways that we
are just starting to understand um
i was talking to russell brand a week
ago you know and he talked about
voiceless people
and how we're increasingly becoming
voiceless and i thought
well wait a second that's true in one
sense perhaps
but it's very untrue in another sense
that might be more important because now
everyone's a tv station if they want to
be and everyone's a radio station if
they want to be and everyone's a
publishing house if they want to be
it's right there at their fingertips and
there's no
apart from impediments that get thrown
up now and then like youtube banning
people and so on
it's it's if you want to have a voice
all you have to do is
buy a 100 microphone and use your laptop
and bang you know
you have whatever audience you can draw
in
yeah and so and that that that is
playing itself out in our culture
extraordinarily rapidly and so
maybe maybe that's just like the 4chan
discussion that's drawn from your book
the new right the culture's moved past
that that's already history
it might be the case that the the
continued dominance of the main
narrative
by the legacy media types that's already
done we're just
mopping up the ashes uh that that's ex
that's exactly my perspective and this
is why it's often so frustrating
with me on social media because i think
it's inevitable
i don't see how if my if i'm the new
york times or if i see
i ask myself this question fairly often
i said if i'm cnn
what could i do to regain the trust of
this young population like what steps
would i take
and they're really in a bad it's it's
like marlboro
like one of my quotes is i said the
battle is one when the average american
regards a corporate journalist exactly
as they regard a tobacco executive
you are never going to have the guy who
runs marlborough
be someone that you trust and think is
like an
unwitting unmitigated good person you
understand his job you might say
look these have to be legal it's a
horrible habit of
and so on and so forth and i get how
he's getting a paycheck and i get how it
could be used in moderation
but regardless this is there's better
ways to improve humanity than
selling tobacco well i i look at the bbc
for example
um tried to to formulate a channel for
young people and
they did exactly what you'd expect
appeal to progressive causes and
yeah the truth of the that didn't work
at all and and why didn't it work it's
because
for young people broadcast tv is so dead
that they don't even notice the corpse
yeah like right right it's it's just
not there it's just not an issue and no
wonder because
the technological advantage of of
on-demand video both production and
consumption is so
that the advantage of that is so
great that those old forms are just
they're terminally dead
and so when i go and and have an
interview with a tv
person you know it feels like i'm going
back into the 70s
and i'm not doing them anymore for and i
can get into that in in a little while
but
what happens is you know the the person
that you're talking to isn't the person
and whatever it is that you're having
isn't a conversation
we're having a conversation when we're
doing this right
you know i'm sure we bring our flaws to
this and our in our arbitrary
preconceptions and our biases and all
that but
my sense is that when a podcast goes
well
i can tell because i'm interested in the
conversation
and the reason i'm interested in the
conversation isn't because i'm i've got
some viewpoints that i'm hammering
forward that you have to attend to but
that i've got some ideas that i can
throw at you
and then i can see what you do with the
ideas and take them apart and add what
you can to them
and then i can have different ideas and
and
and we can do that collaboratively over
the course of the dialogue and we can
include
all the people that are watching this in
the process and
that's like it's like this long form
allows for
the truth being something like an
investigation into the truth
instead of the truth and right
well we don't want to underestimate how
much of that is purely a consequence of
the technological revolution
because now there's time right we can
make mistakes and
and and and it doesn't matter because
the bandwidth is unlimited
yeah if i'm a roulette player player and
i mention this in the book as well all
my money is on technology being what
saves us
i do not i think politics literally only
causes problems and it's not a place for
any kind of solution you cannot look to
washington for solutions
uh what's funny is when you listen to
corporate media
a lot of times they will acknowledge
something's a problem but then when that
problem is solved
exterior to it they start to panic we
have heard
you and i are both old enough to
remember that there was a lot of
hand-wringing
correctly that we live in a sound bite
culture
that it's not reasonable that a
politician who might have a new
innovative way to save solve for poverty
to solve for the environment to solve
for you know out of wedlock births
they have some program but they have to
wrap it up in 10 seconds
it's very hard to make that point and as
a result this rewards glib people
or people who have good one-liners but
someone who's inarticulate who has great
ideas
that person is going to be dead in the
water and that's going to create results
that we
necessarily like so then people like you
know what this is true like you have
people talking past each other
the republican versus democrat you know
broadly what you're they're going to say
it's fun when they get a zinger in but
i'm not going to have the needle moved
i'm rooting for my team
and it's kind of a sports phenomenon
podcasts come along
we're going to have a long conversation
where both of us are listening to each
other
i might disagree with you i don't have a
political party behind me neither do i
hopefully you'll disagree with me
hopefully okay that you'll do hold on
not only will you disagree
but more importantly that you'll do it
in an interesting way that's interesting
also to
me because yeah if you disagree with me
there is some possibility that you know
something i don't
and if you disagree i could learn
something from you yeah the smartest
person
the smartest person is ignorant of 99.99
of knowledge we that i mean this is the
the mistake that these kind of
overeducated people think they think
just because i'm smart i know everything
you're still going to be profoundly
ignorant you're just going to be
knowledgeable about certain things very
specifically but getting back to
the point i was saying earlier now that
we have these long conversations and
people can really delve into ideas
and if people listening to us might
think we're both full of crap but now
they're
at least challenging their own views and
being like why do i disagree with both
of them
you don't have that space on cnn by
nature of its organization
and now what cnn and other outlets had
correctly posited as a problem
has been resolved but it's been resolved
their expense so now the the human cry
is
there's misinformation people are being
told dangerous ideas yeah it's dangerous
to your agenda
it's it's dangerous to your prominence
uh
cnn brian stelter had a whole segment i
don't think he named timpool by name
by saying how is it that these youtube
shows news shows
have orders of magnitude bigger than us
what do we do about this it's like
this is literally every market like i'm
a publisher or i make apples
someone comes along their apples are
people like those apples better
you know you don't call in the state you
don't regardless some kind of
uh you know abomination against the
natural order of things
you're like okay crap what are they what
nerve that is tim striking
that i can learn from but they're never
interested in that
because they're not interested in
learning they're interested in teaching
or more specifically training their
audiences
what to think and believe and you see
this in social media i made this joke
over the weekend
in the same way that christians regard
the trinity as one god and three person
you have these entire populations which
is one mind
in many many persons because the people
will watch
john oliver or they'll watch you know
some other show on the right
and the next day not only will they be
repeating these views
but they're repeating them verbatim and
that is when you realize
oh there's no mind there this we're
trained since we're kids correctly
that it's important for us to be
informed on current events
so what these shows do very uh
perniciously
is they will bring up an issue that the
person hadn't heard about before which
is important for us to understand sure
but immediately we'll train them on how
to look at this issue and what the
correct
emotional response is and people are
hungry for that because
they want to present themselves as
informed but they don't have the time or
the capacity
uh to uh undertake the critical or
independent thought to do that
so it comes prepackaged for them so it's
kind of the tv dinner
of the mind well that's a good metaphor
but the the
the the network format all of it
the whole technological apparatus
including the corporate funding
as a consequence of the expense of
bandwidth absolutely
demands that you know like i never feel
more like
content than when i go to a tv station
and everyone in there is is is in some
sense held hostage to the limitations
and advantages of that particular
technology and
you know what well as marshall mcluhan
said the medium is the message
you know and yeah a lot of what a lot of
what looks like
even corporate think or corporate
malfeasance is
merely a consequence of that strange
technological limitation the
the the networks have to assume that
everybody watching has no memory and no
education and no attention span because
the bandwidth requirements demand that
and now that's all gone
so let me ask you about this so now all
of a sudden
the network everyone's a tv station okay
so now
one thing that that that the
dominance let's say of the three major
tv stations from
say 1950 or thereabouts till 1995 maybe
something like that
there was the imposition of something
like a coherent
uh um national narrative and now you can
object to that and you should because
in some sense it's imposed but but you
know it's
it's a collaborative imposition between
these technologically powerful companies
and the government the journalists
couldn't go
to couldn't be too corrupt if they
chased after the politicians because
then they wouldn't get access and
the politicians couldn't be too corrupt
because the media would
you know disrobe them but there was this
sense of unity and now you get this
immense multiplicity and so
i mean you're more anarchically oriented
i would say temperamentally than i am
but
i am an anarchist yes right right but
you know there is there is a danger in
fragmentation
that's the i mean that's diversity is
fragmentation but
but you know enough fragmentation you
get nothing but endless conflict
as people try to work out how they're
going to cooperate
so i i don't think that's necessarily
true because i don't think it's i think
you're taking it as a given that
cooperation is desirable
or that this unity of some kind is
desirable i think what's coming up
in certain circles which i was the first
one to posit this in 2015
is in america at least the idea of a
national divorce uh
recognizing that we've had at least two
cultures since the very beginning
they're being held together through you
know often nefarious means
and if one group regards donald trump as
literally hitler and an authoritarian
strong man which you can
very easily make the case for that and
the other group regards you know
joe biden is basically someone sitting
in his own urine behind the resolute
desk
there's no reason other than some kind
of sense of inertia
for these two two or more groups
to be under the same polity or both
there's no reason for you to have the
president you don't want
and increasingly as conversation becomes
and discourse collapses
uh because i think social media does
tend to drive our ideologies to their
logical conclusions which leads to
extremism which could be both a good
thing or a bad thing
it is going to be harder and harder to
the point where it's impossible
to you know have this uh sort of
conversation and we're seeing it also in
europe
okay but there are reasons for for the
the necessity of the unity i mean
so you talk about jonathan height in the
in the
in your book in the new right and
there's a lot of uh
psychological investigators myself
included when i was doing research who
were looking into the temperamental
basis of political affiliation right
and so you know roughly speaking on the
left end of things you get the high
open people who are creative in their
thinking and and yes
and who who are temperamentally in favor
of the free flow of information
um and tend to be lower in
conscientiousness particularly
orderliness and then you have
people who lie on the other side of that
who are higher in orderliness and lower
in openness and
i tried to figure out why that was the
fundamental political axis
because there's five temperaments yes so
why only those two as the major
determinants of political
affiliation and it what it boiled down
to me
for me is that and i think this this
isn't my discovery precisely but i think
it's the most significant discovery in
political psychology in the last 50
years is that
it's probably that because borders
are the fundamental political issue and
i don't just mean borders between
countries i mean borders between
concepts i mean borders between
categories
countries states towns people the
conservative types think
you have to hold things together yep
because if they dissolve they die and
the liberal types think well wait a
second you bloody well need to maximize
information flow and the truth of the
matter is sometimes one of those
perspectives is right for that situation
and sometimes the other and it's cont
i mean even with look at the advantages
of free trade
and then the disadvantage of you know a
worldwide
epidemic that's a great example it's
like well are open borders good
well they do facilitate the transmission
of disease
and it turns out that the probability
that infectious disease will be
transmitted in a given political locale
is actually a very good determinant of
political belief within that locale
so wherever there's more infectious
disease people are much more
conservative
and it's a huge effect so something very
fundamental is going on at the bottom of
our political thinking but
having said all that it's that also
means
you know that both of those types are
necessary because sometimes one has the
right solution and sometimes the other
but
even more importantly is that there's no
way of
getting rid of that dichotomy if you
have groups of human beings and so if we
can't
imp if we can't have a unity emerge that
allows both those types of people to
coexist
then what we're going to have as a
consequence is conflict
like and who knows how severe that can
become so we have we don't have a
we have a choice it's like unity however
fragile that might be
or the degeneration into something like
like conflict
and that's not preferable to cooperation
all things considered
oh i disagree i think it is comparable
and i don't think the alternatives
excuse me i don't think the unity means
cooperation i think unity means
oppression
well sometimes you look look i i i don't
disagree with that
in some sense i'm saying all the time
unity through politics always means
oppression because the political system
can only be used to silence people and
force them to do what they otherwise
would not want to do
otherwise they would do it on a
voluntary basis so any of these calls of
unity
in my view are you are always slight of
hand
to marginalize or oppress a certain
population
now sometimes that's necessary classic
post-modernism that that
post-modernist that's the fundamental
claim of the power theorists the french
power theorists
and there's there's some i'm that's not
an insult by the way
sure um but but
look if you take 10 kids and you have
them play the same game
all the kids get to play the game but
not all of them get to play the game
they wanted to at that moment
but at least they all get to play a game
and so
there's cooperation there and there's
utility in it now you can say well the
the tyranny of the game has been imposed
and that's true but
both of those things are true at the
same time and it doesn't seem reasonable
to
equate cooperation with tyranny it's
reasonable to point out that cooperation
can degenerate into tyranny
i think you just kind of uh um drop the
mask a little bit
because you in your example positive
these are children
so by its very nature all these things
that you're talking about in a positive
sense
have to force some group to be a
second-class citizen or at least
obedient to some kind of elite uh and
this is something that i think is
the benefits of this at the very least
are enormously overblown
i think you could freedom means every
kid can play the game that they want
uh their mind but not with other people
that's the problem
you know so and i used children as an
example because i was concentrating on
games and
because it's out of games that the
polity emerges
over the course of its natural
development so it's not a rational
top-down imposition all things
considered it's the
it's the emergence of a game-like
structure that incorporates more and
more people and
see the if if you take two-year-olds
two-year-olds play their own game
and and and each of them plays their own
game but by the time they hit three or
four
they have to be able to integrate the
game they're playing with
with what other children want to play so
that they can play
they can play games with other children
which they're unbelievably motivated to
do
and it means that each of them have to
subordinate their instincts so to speak
for the moment but hypothetically they
gain as a consequence of
their mutual subordination to this
higher order game i i don't see it as
support so if my choices are play this
game by myself
or play this game i like second with a
lot of other people
i i would value this it's the i'm i'm
playing a game in order to have fun
so in that case the first game which i
which is my most favorite game
if no one wants to play with me it's not
going to be that fun so i am it is
rational
and not at any sense of subordination to
choose my second preferred game
because now i'm having fun being able to
play it well
let's look i would say that what we're
doing here
is a is a game and i don't mean that in
any
you know in any um what negative sense
you're allowing by participating in this
conversation you're allowing for the
possibility
and the belief i would say that whatever
we're doing collaboratively is of more
utility
at the moment than whatever you could be
doing individually at the moment
because otherwise you won't be doing it
okay so and i would say that we
we are cooperating we're also competing
and we also might be tyrannizing each
other to some degree
but there's something in this mutual
interaction that we're
about that we're we're engaging in
voluntarily that is cooperative
and that isn't being enforced by some
external agent right it's entirely
cooperative and this is my whole point
this is why i'm an anarchist because
this is when people are doing things
voluntarily they are going to choose the
things that are preferable to them
the problem and when you have conflict
is when you have a third actor coming
into our conversation
and being the state and forcing both of
us to do something we would not want to
do for their sake
and that when you play that out that
game on a national international scale
that is the definition of oppression
instead of you and i having a podcast
why aren't we in the factory making
socks for poor people
uh that's more utility says the you know
the third party who's not involved here
and that's the danger in my view and the
legitimacy of that kind of third party
it is
so the development i i
picked up a reasonable number of my
ideas about the relationship between
games and morality and higher order
social structures from
the developmental psychologist jean
piaget and he was interested in
the science of ethics essentially and
his goal was the re
reunification of science and religion
actually although
very few people know that about psja and
he pointed out quite clearly that
um a cooperative game would out-compete
a tyrannical game over time because
the tyrannical game had to waste
resources in enforcement whereas
a cooperative game didn't because people
were voluntarily
going to go along with it um so that
then you say well
it's i think you can make a perfectly
credible case that if you could choose
between
two games and one of them involved force
and the other
didn't and they had the same end let's
say that
the cooperative game is to be preferred
and it's also more sophisticated
but i would say as well we actually
don't know how to pull that off
some of it's just just lack of ability
well when you integrate so many people
like you have 330 million people in the
united states
it's really hard hard to organize a
cooperative game
well that's the role of the corporate
press the corporate press uh puts forth
the agenda of the power class
and gets everyone persuaded to do uh
that which they had wanted to do mario
cuomo whose book i got
sorry andrew cuomo the governor of new
york whose book i got paid to read
he said explicitly in his book that if
this wasn't done through voluntary
compliance i wouldn't be able to pull
off half of this
and what what what is allowed to happen
is you have decentralized enforcement of
these
uh rules and we saw this during the
lockdowns where every low-status person
had an opportunity with certain
dominance over somebody else by going up
to them
and yelling at them that they're not
wearing a mask even though going up to
them ostensibly
is going to put your life in danger and
just
you made a very cogent point about how
persuasion is a lot
cheaper than force a lot of people use
all these orwellian 1984 comparisons and
i think the comparison to contemporary
terms
is much closer to brave new world and
it's through the use of pleasure and the
carrot
because it's a lot cheaper to tell
people persuade people it's in their
best interest
go along uh you're going to give up your
freedom but i'm going to give you safety
and they'll be champing at the bit to do
that h.l menken the great cynic of the
um
early 20th century uh said that the
average man does not want to be free he
simply wants to be safe
and for those of us who are fans of
freedom who regard liberty as a high
value
the issue is how do you engage in a
polity
with people who don't really find
liberty of use and would rather have
every minute of their life
whether through their corporate job or
what they watch on tv or what they wear
pretty much decided for them i mean the
the speech in the devil wears prada
that miranda priestly makes about how
you're wearing that blue sweater
because the people in this room you know
chose the cerulean jacket five years ago
then it went to the fringe designers
then it became in the mall then you
found it on clearance
and you think it has nothing to do with
you but it was because we had made these
decisions and it percolated down to
you and i think that top down approach i
mean ed bernays talked about this walter
littman talked about this
in the books propaganda and public
opinion this was something that they
figured out
a hundred years ago specifically during
the woodrow wilson administration
how do you get over the complete you
know fascist takeover of the united
states of course under wartime
premises and get everyone involved in
something that would have been
completely alien to american thought
just five years prior
that we're gonna send all our kids over
to europe
to fight a european war this was a major
revolutionary shift in how america
regarded its relationship between the
state and the population
and between america and the rest of the
world woodrow wilson was the first
president
to leave america as president fdr just
went to panama but that was like
american territory at the time
uh sorry teddy roosevelt so this was
that's what so we've been they've been
at this for a hundred years
so they're playing the long game and now
it's starting to fall apart thankfully
okay so i i got three things i want to
ask you now
sure i want to know who they is
okay so then i want to know in the devil
were prada
were you on miranda priestly's side or
on the side of the
naive injunu who you know was
hypothetically tyrannized by her
and now i can't remember the third one
we'll we'll stick with those two for the
time being
so who's the they exactly sure so
because it's a shorthand right and it's
a conspiratorial shorthand so it's worth
pa it's worth unpacking
sure a conspiracy is just an
organization that you don't approve of
the constitutional convention was a
conspiracy the founding fathers got
together in philadelphia
to reorganize the artists of
confederation that was what they had
been their assigned tasks that they had
sworn to
they get in there lock the doors they go
yeah we're starting over right guys like
yeah
yeah and they swore themselves to
secrecy now we don't say conspiracy
because
we don't like that term but this was
very much a conspiracy okay
conspiracies usually involve deception
and secretiveness too so
they they swore themselves to secrecy
philadelphia and there's a
conspiratorial element there for sure
but
there's lots of things that people do
behind the scenes so to speak that
aren't necessarily conspiratorial
because they do them
they're not hiding them so but back to
the they
you know so basically so the model is
you get the kids at a very young age
and you put them in government schools
they are taught many things that are
nefarious such as
that your self-esteem should be a
function of this mediocre person from
the room
uh that everyone should have the same
work hours that you're forced to be in a
relationship with
violent peers that in no other situation
are you forced to be locked into a
relationship with them with like bullies
or just people who are
you know disruptive um but this it
starts with the universities
and this was by design the american
economics association
which was started i think in the late uh
1890s by richard eli who was woodrow
wilson's mentor
there and they use they always use
orwellian language uh
country myself but the idea is we're
training the next generation of elites
so basically you have an entire
population who go to these best
universities
who are taught the same faith and this
was they had something at a time
which has degenerated now called the
social gospel uh
the quote what would jesus do which
contemporary christians say all the time
this was posited by a socialist
christian
because the idea was instead of an
individual soul being able to be saved
which was kind of the central idea of
christianity and a big innovation in
terms of
historical individualism the premise was
a nation has a soul and a nation can be
saved now once a nation has a soul and
can be saved
there is nothing outside your purview
just like when we're talking about
individual soul the bedroom
the boardroom how you are in public
these all tie into your salvation
um and eli and other in
um in the uk it was the fabian society
whose logo was literally a wolf in
sheep's clothing
the premise of was it's kind of
gramsci's march the institutions
we're going to train the next generation
of leaders they're going to
self-identify as leaders because they
have the diplomas and degrees
and they're going to go out there and
basically be infect
and take over the country and it's going
to be this top down idea
and you see that it's it's percolated
through this day so you have it starts
with universities
then you have all the journalists and
people working media who are trained at
these universities and the same ideas
and then the final consequence is uh the
politicians now for decades what had
happened was
you had the nancy's pelosi of the world
go on tv
and say truthfully and honestly give me
money
re-elect me i'm fighting mitch mcconnell
and the wicked republicans
and the mitch's mcconnell went on tv and
say give me money
i'm fighting nancy pelosi and the
democrats meanwhile while these two are
engaging this pantomime
the new york times harvard are lobbing
grenades over their shoulders and
they're not taking any fire at all
what has happened now is people are
realizing people like biden
mcconnell these are puppets of larger
actors
and that's where the focus needs to be
in terms of affecting change and
liberating uh the west
okay okay so so let me let me act as
defender of the patriarchy momentarily
sure and so and and to and i remember i
remember the third question and this
relates back to 4chan is what
and and to anarchism for that matter is
that there's this
there's this critique of the social
contract that's obviously in order and
needs to continue and the satirists and
so forth
are are our right to do what they do but
then there's the
separate issue of what responsibility
you owe your polity and
so and maybe none you could make that
case but
but i want to address that but but in
any case let's look at the elite
institutions in the united states and
what's happened to them over the last 40
years for better for worse so i know i
know
how this worked so
a hundred years ago harvard yale the ivy
leagues
they were essentially aristocratic
institutions and you were
in them as a consequence of birth okay
by the 1960s that changed and it changed
to iq based meritocracy
okay the sat is an iq test now people
swear up and down it's not but that's
because they don't know anything about
iq tests
right so to make an iq test all you have
to do is
draw 20 random questions from a set of
abstract questions
sum up the right answers and rank order
them
across the population that's basically
all an iq test is it's that powerful
an sat is an iq test now increasingly at
the elite levels
in the universities iq is the
determining
entrance requirement and the average iq
of people in the ivy league schools has
gone up precipitously since the early
1960s
when it wasn't much higher than average
and now it's way higher than average now
you can debate about whether or not
that's a good thing that's a separate
issue but that is what's happened
and the reason there was a bunch of
reasons for that i mean one was
the realization that iq is actually the
best predictor of success
in colleges it's not that good but it's
five times as good as the next best
predictor
and it's also relatively fair in that
your your sat scores are um
they're a better determinant of your
success in university than which school
you graduated from
so a very very bright kid from a very
bad school has a
reasonable shot at ivy league admission
um compared to say a very bad scoop
student at a very
uh elite school yeah so there were
socialists who were pushing the use of
iq as well as people
who are more conservative but in any
case there's no
there's no conspiracy at work there
precisely there's
there's a decision on the part of the
institutions as a whole
that it would be better for the elite
institutions to be based on merit
as as assessed by iq and that overall
that would be better for the general
population because
hypothetically having smarter people
make decisions
because they can make decisions using
more information is better for all
concerned and so that's
so there's a lot more going on at the
upper ends of the elite
institutions let's say then the mere
conservation of
of multi-generational power there's a
positive element that that
that i think is overlooked to
in in a in a way that looks to me like
the shirking of responsibility
in revolutionary movements like those
even that are spawned off of 4chan
or that characterize anarchism it's like
well what responsibility do you have to
what it is that's brought you to the
point where for example you can have
this technology-mediated conversation
with me
criticize a way but like where's the
where's the
where's the emphasis on where's the
positive contribution and and perhaps
even the gratitude
it's in the toilet where it belongs i
mean i reject totally the idea that
somehow
i oh we're on zoom right now i've got a
mic uh
from uh i don't even know what brand
what i owe them
is the cost that it paid me to buy their
product
and what i owe you is to treat you with
which isn't much of a cost at all
with courtesy dignity and respect uh
anytime people start talking about
duties and responsibilities and
gratitude
that's them invoking uh the unearned
wait wait
no no i don't i don't i don't think i
don't think it's that cut and dried
even in your formulation because you
said
well you pay for it and fine i'll leave
that be and
say that's a perfectly acceptable answer
but you did say that
you know that there's a that that you
believe that you have a moral obligation
to what we're engaged in right now right
you're going to treat me with you you
said three words dignity respect
something else
courtesy yeah courtesy so so you do
recognize that there's a there's an
ethos that should govern
our interactions no i think you've
earned all those things
i don't care everyone's fine that that i
have no problem with that but
but and i i i'm not trying to undermine
your argument either i'm
i'm really curious about this issue of
responsibility because i pushed it a lot
you know and i've tried to figure out
what response so look
from my perspective i would say well
your
your thought centers on the tyrannical
element of the great father
and like yes fair enough like that's a
major existential concern
so in terms of problems to focus on it's
a major problem it's not
the only problem but it's a major
problem you know you could focus on the
evil in your own soul
you could focus on the catastrophes of
the natural world
well those are valid dope large-scale
domains of concern as well
but but for me it's like okay well there
is the tyrannical aspect
but there's the there there's the aspect
of culture that well that you have
enough food to eat that you have heat
and that you have
you're the beneficiary of the structure
that you're criticizing and
you could say well my criticism is
making the structure stronger but
there's this element in your in your
book and then on in the 4chan culture
and so forth it seems to have this like
it's this random destructiveness that
that
that looks to me it's not driven by it's
not driven by something that's going to
be
clearly spoken of and it's not driven by
something that's aiming at a good end
i i think it's aiming toward a more
honest end
because very often we're told things
like this person's a hero that person's
a hero they should be valorized
and even if that conclusion is accurate
you know
who are you to tell me that i need to
valorize that person i mean one thing if
it's like showing versus telling like
good writing right if you tell me this
person has this accomplishment that
accomplishment
that accomplishment the natural rational
responses this is a quality person and
we need more i would love it if there
was a world that had more people like
this
but if there's so many outlets more than
you can count
greta thunderberg is a great example you
have some random high school dropout
who won't go to back to school until
literally everyone on earth changes the
weather for her
and time magazine is calling her person
the year i think to have that
undermining
of time magazine and i got to tell you
there's lots of things you could say
positive about her
you know that's very easy she's made
something of herself
but it's time magazine that's far more
of the target
than her it's these agencies that
presume
to tell me who i should respect and
value
and it's not on my terms it's on their
self-serving terms you don't need to
tell me that black lives matter i know
this
i'm from brooklyn and you don't need to
tell me literally every five seconds
uh and only we decide altogether that
they matter this month
and then next week it's going to be gay
history so trans labs are going to
matter
then we go back to black lives mattering
it's like so what if
fine fair enough you know that's that's
a that's a
compelling sequence of statements it's
like what is it exactly i'm not being
smart i mean that i know no i i i
that's something i would say when i am
being smart so that's why okay okay you
know well
but but i'm i'm that's a compelling
series of statements that is
observing it i'm observing it you know
because
you put the argument you put the
argument forward with force
yeah and it's interesting to me to
listen okay so i know there's something
to it
so i'm trying to figure out exactly what
it is so then i think to myself well
what exactly is it that you're objecting
to like is it
no you said well it's flavor it's moral
flavor of the month
it's something like that and it's the
imposition of the moral flavor of the
month that's objectionable and that's
somehow
tied to the contempt the this elitist
contempt
and i think that's fair but so but
it's the question to say you say they
and the they contains the enemy in some
sense and so
my question is well exactly what is the
enemy and who is the enemy and where is
it
exactly and uh harvard yard uh
the new york times offices and uh
congress and the white house
and corporations oh absolutely okay
where isn't it it isn't
right here you and i okay why because
why right here and now
why isn't it here right here and now
i'll tell you why because
neither of us are doing anything other
than presenting our own perspective
we are letting people agree with us or
disagree with us
from their own choice it's not going to
matter to me or to you whether someone
agrees or disagree
you're speaking your truth i'm speaking
mind to use a cliched expression
and at the very least i hope that people
are watching this and being entertained
and having their thoughts provoked
i am not in any way regarding and i
certainly don't have the power to impose
the idea
that if you think i'm a jerk and full of
crap that somehow that makes you a bad
person
or that you should have some kind of
posi social consequence as a result
these different organizations absolutely
do and let me give you one example and
this kind of speaks to
cancer culture which is obviously you
know a very hot topic at the moment
the head of uh crossfit which is you
know this big gay
fitness organization he came out dur
when we were all caring about
specifically black lives matter he said
look
we're about deadlifts and burpees what i
don't know we're
we don't regard races anything we're
about fitness and we're very diverse
what does that do with us and he got
fired a result of this
so again it's fighting against this
that's the big difference
neither of us are in a position to nor
would we i can't speak for you but
i bet you you would agree with me ever
dream of telling someone
this is my example north korea right i
did my book on north korea dear reader
it's an issue that means a lot to me
there's a lot of americans who just
simply don't care
i don't think they're bad people because
i think there's very little they can do
about it there's very little i can do
all i tried to do with my book
was move the needle and have people
perceive the nation and its population
differently
but i haven't liberated north korea so
it's perfectly legitimate if they have
different concerns or if they're not
interested
but this is not how the cathedral works
okay okay so i've been sitting i've been
spending the last when i give a lecture
i i i i know what i'm doing enough to
keep the audience interested
but i also know what i'm doing like i
can say what i'm doing i
i have the practice but also a theory
and they match and so
before i give a lecture i figure out
what
problem i'm addressing i have to have
that question in my mind
and then i have like okay i'm gonna
investigate this problem and i'm gonna
push my thinking more than
i've already pushed it on my feet and
i'm gonna use these eight
tools or places or stories as
investigative tools and then i'm gonna
see what comes out of that and so that's
and if i sit down and i really think
about it think it through
then the lecture will go well and what i
am doing as far as i can tell is
thinking on my feet
and people seem to like watching that
okay now i've been thinking all right
what are we doing in a
tv a standard tv interview and what are
we doing in a podcast because now
i have this podcast and i'm enjoying it
and it's such a thrill for me because
i can reach out to virtually anyone in
the world and say look i'd really like
to find out what you
think and they'll say yes and i can talk
to them and so it's unbelievably
it's an unbelievably great thing to do
and then i've been thinking well
i can feel when it's going well and when
it isn't when it goes flat and when it's
going well we're doing what we're doing
it's kind of engaging and there's a
there's a pugilistic element to it and
but
but there's no rancor there's no
outright
anger um right or it's not directed at
the process we're engaged in this mutual
exploration that's what it looks like to
me and
i've been trying to formalize that so
you know when i have a guest
i have a series of problems that i'd
like to investigate with them
and then i invite them to participate
and so then i think well to me that's
the logos in operation that and that's
why people like it the logos is this
it's exploratory verbal activity
something like that
and people really like that and i talked
to a
wall street journalist journal
journalist the other week about podcasts
and
he said that the reason he likes them is
because he doesn't know where they're
going to go
yes right exactly right so they're so in
they're they're agenda-less in that
sense right because yes and
it's and sincere in that sense because
you have to have some element of honesty
if it's improv
yes exactly well and i also think these
new forms really punish
people who don't engage in that so like
now and then i'll talk to a podcast host
who's a legacy journalist
and they'll slip into well here's a
question it's like
yeah yeah is that your question or is
that a
question you know and it's sort of like
a lecturer who reads the
powerpoint slides instead of talking
spontaneously about the topic
i i completely agree and i think this
also speaks to why
this kind of mechanism for conversation
is so popular
people very rarely and even you and i
i mean have the opportunity to see two
intelligent informed people
who might disagree about things have
that long conversation with virtually no
possibility of it being hostile if it's
not at a party so you can hear each
other
you can listen to it at your own leisure
and you're going to be
learning something or you're at the very
least gonna have it's just fascinating
conversational dynamics
even if you and i were arguing over cake
versus pie and which is better
and obviously the answer is cake because
pies are messy but at the same time it's
fun
because they're watching minds at work
it's just like when you're watching
a gymnast for example it's a great
dancer it's just exciting to see an
aspect of the human mind the human
anatomy
at its finest or maybe we're getting a b
i don't know
but the point is to watch that engine
yeah but when you see
corp when you see corporate anything
it's always
unnatural there's is there anything more
ironic
than the expression reality tv by its
own nature they admit this is not real
the it's a lot of it's improv it's all
staged it's all edited
uh whereas what we're doing we're not
editing and we're going to say almond ah
and you know oh yeah we're going to have
the spree descalier we're going to cut
off the mics and i'm like oh gosh i wish
i would have said that and
you're going to say something else but
that i think is what
uh earnestness in a positive sense
people
are missing out and that's the opposite
of corporate america
corporate america is synthetic phony
earnestness i
i had this quote i say if you look at
times square during gay pride only
corporate america
can make sodomy and perversion seem
downright boring
i mean if you looked at the corporate
presentation of people who are gay
you think what that means is hugging
each other after brunch
and and shaking hands it's it's this
complete
divorce from uh any kind of reality of
any kind of culture
i would say that
the the the attribution of this
the identification of this with
corporate america with the universities
with
with the legacy media all of that it's
it's not it's like the marxists
criticizing capitalism for inequality of
distribution
it's like inequality of distribution is
a way deeper problem than any critique
of capitalism will ever
formulate properly or solve and i would
say like
we're we're getting at something here
that
transcends the anarchist critique of
structure
not at least as it like or or you could
say
or you could say forces it deeper look
the old
the the ancient egyptians had two gods
osiris and horus and osiris
they didn't have two they had a ton of
them yes they had two main gods that
made up their conception of sovereignty
sorry yes
that the pharaoh modeled himself again
over
modeled himself on the interaction of
these two gods
there was osiris who was the state for
all intents and purposes
structure per se and his sin was willful
blindness and
and um and and and stultification
and horus was the attentive eye
and in other formulations the ability to
speak
and so there's a dynamic there that was
recognized a very long time ago that
that that that that centers on this
issue that you brought up about
sincerity and truth
you know you're complaining and rightly
so when you hear stale repackaged ideas
that are being presented for reasons
other than the actual reason it's
something like that isn't it it's like
i can't trust what you're saying because
you're actually using that language
to manipulate me to do something that
you're not stating
correct and and that would be mountain
dew and the naming it's like isn't this
fun it's like well maybe it's fun but
really you want to sell
you know mountain dew and if you came
out and said that we wouldn't make fun
of you but if you're going to pretend
we're going to go after you and when it
gets very pernicious it's you're
claiming you're fighting racism but what
you're really wanting is to promote war
and killing of many many people so that
is when the critique is more than
mountain dew is what it is it's selling
it's mountain dew is fun
i enjoy mountain dew i don't drink it
much because i'm in my late 80s but
basically kids like it the different
colors different flavors
it certainly serves a purpose you know
you want to get buzzed out of your mind
and the caffeine
more power to you there's nothing other
than some cavities there's nothing
really nefarious
there is something very nefarious when
amy rohrbach is caught on a hot mic
saying that they had everything on
prince philip or prince albert i always
get them confused uh
who was friends with jeffrey epstein
that they had everything on the clintons
and they got a call from bubba
buckingham palace
and because there was a megan markel
interview you know on the table
that they killed this entire story this
is her talking in a hot mic
meanwhile if that camera turned off and
you said is it true
that you had this international
pedophile ring and one of the people in
buckingham kallus was involved
and that you know their lawyers called
and you killed the story she would say
are you crazy that's a conspiracy theory
harvey weinstein is another example of
this there was a conspiracy
we all knew uh bill cosby was another
one he got outed by hannibal burris who
was a comedian who just said look it up
all this stuff was bubbling under all
these women they weren't all completely
silent so i think that's the big
difference between mountain dew
and the corporate press we're not
talking about people who are promoting
cavities we're talking about people who
are promoting war and depravity
okay so if i said well maybe
when i was when i was reading your book
and thinking about it
a lot and thinking about 4chan and all
of the things we've talked about i
thought well
have you been on 4chan since you have
you actually looked at it
no i'm i'm complete i'm ignorant about
how 4chan works
so it's just a message board right right
well i i guess i knew that much but i
would also say i'm not familiar enough
with message boards to re
to really you know to have us a built-in
sense of what that means
that's not an area of social
communication that i've engaged in and
i'm not saying that with pride
it's a form of ignorance you know i mean
i've learned
not to despise social media platforms
you're a fool if you allow your
willingness to despise them because you
don't know anything about them to stop
you from learning how to use them right
or from taking them seriously they're
serious those things so
oh yes they're revolutionary those
technic okay so
i read and i think well wait a second
you're
you seem to be um not
segregating the critique of corruption
from the critique of structure
and this is also what i think is
happening with the postmodernists they
look at hierarchies and they think well
they're all based on power and here's
the evidence of corruption it's like
yeah no kidding
but that doesn't mean they're only based
on power
and it's the same with corporations like
i know lots of people who work in
corporate environments and some of them
are really admirable
and the things they do in the corporate
environments are also admirable and i
would also say that my experience has
taught me that
when corporations start to act the way
you conceptualize them theirs
their their doom is sealed far more
rapidly than people generally realize
they collapse so so you're not objective
so it's useful to disaggregate the
critique of structure from the
critique of deceit you know what i
i think the deceits baked in i i don't
like using the word corruption because
that implies these people can be saved
and these organizations can be saved
i do not believe that they are and even
if they are i'm not interested in saving
them
see i don't see them as this is the they
problem you see
look part of the reason i think do you
want to talk about walter durante
i mean you want to talk about walter
durante these are this these are the
same
exact actors that have had so much blood
on their hand for
hands for decades and have never had any
accountability let me give you one
example
we could always think that that's me
not them i don't i don't why is that you
you don't work for the let me give you
one example you can answer if you say
this sounds like you we're all taught in
school about william randolph hearst
the spanish-american war remember the
main yellow journalism right
and how the media would gin up these
problems
which had literally thousands of deaths
that
needless debts as a consequence then
there's a record scratch
and all of a sudden all these outlets
have no agenda
and are objective and our decent actors
my point is there was never a record
scratch
this has always been a problem for a
very long time and
especially this is something i would
think would be very much up your alley
the amount that these um organizations
and and
the equivalence of contemporary actors
have their role
in putting over and maintaining the
soviet union and specifically stalinism
which they have never apologized for
which they've had never
no accountability for and now they're
presuming to sit here and lecture
the layman about being a decent person
and being responsible
that to me is a complete abomination
i agree with all of that except the
attribution of blame
so let me ask you i'm going to go
sideways just for a second but it's in
service of this particular discussion
you said a little while ago that you
were
you know that one of the rules of
engagement for us as far as you're
concerned right now is that you were
going to treat
me with dignity respect and there was
something else courtesy
courtesy okay okay and then i said well
you know those are the cooperative rules
and you said to me no you earned it and
so i want to ask you like
and then we'll go back to this other
discussion if that's okay um
what makes you think i've earned it
because i know a lot of people whose
lives you have personally made better
because you're my friend's dad so that
automatically there's no situation where
i'm going to be
mean to my friend or disrespectful to my
friend's dad certainly not in public
um i think you are in many ways
self-made uh the fact that you are a
successful author and you're encouraging
a lot of people
to you know get their crap together and
and you're not telling them
one of the things i tell and and this is
something you and i have in common
is you're not you don't the goal isn't
to be a perfect person
but you could certainly be a better
person tomorrow than you are yesterday
and if you have that in your mind you
could say that objectively with a
straight face
that goes a long way towards fighting
feelings of anxiety or depression
or hopelessness because when that voice
in your brain which we all have
is telling you you you're never going to
find another job you're never
gonna find another girlfriend look at
you're sitting around playing video
games you're gonna wait a minute
i went to the gym today and i've got the
numbers here
that shows i lifted more than last week
i'm objectively
improved in one capacity that is
enormous people don't
i should talk to you you're absolutely
right about that i was stopped by three
separate people this week
who said they they thanked me and and so
whenever that no one likes it no one
likes a show off jordan
when when that happens i have i i always
ask people what their name is
to begin with because they're usually
they want to be seen
well they don't know if they should
interact with me they don't know if
they're being rude
they don't want to look stupid you know
there's it's complicated but if i ask
them their name
and then engage then they calm down
right away and then they'll talk to me
but what i want to find out always if
someone says
well you were helpful i want to find out
okay well
exactly why right what did i do that
fixed that help you because then i can
do it better
hypothetically so three people told me
the same thing this week
which is exactly the point that you just
made which is quite cool was that they
restructured their internal reward
system they stopped comparing themselves
with other people
well you know stopped but yeah yeah
started to stop
and they started to learn how to reward
themselves for making incremental
improvements
so that was really cool and and i do
think that you picked up picked up
something there that's absolutely
crucial
so but but then i could also say to you
well look i'm also the face of the
professoriate
because yeah i know right right so so
but
but what that so what does that signify
to you does it signify that i'm an
outlier or that
no it just means you'll be the last one
up against the wall
no it's in all seriousness one of the
points i have made recently
is that as awful as corporate
journalists are
and as humorless and self-righteous and
pompous they are still better by all
these metrics than university professors
and i'm not speaking about you
personally
but you can if you look at the thing
that twitter did so amazingly
is that back in the and i'm thinking of
someone specifically who i'll um
i'll mention in a second back in the day
you would think
i'm a harvard law professor that if i
don't even know who this person is
that's going to tell me certain
information this is one of the highest
quality minds in america
this person knows his industry inside
and out if he tells me something
i can take it to the bank and that's
actually true because harvard the
harvard law faculty is making the law in
america far more than congress because
it's their interpretation
and those people are trained then you
look at lawrence tribe
uh on twitter and you look that he is
tweeting
exactly verbatim the same kind of
miserable
anti-trump things that your spinster
aunt is tweeting and you realize wait a
minute
this emperor has no clothes this person
might be very bright which
there's no question he's brilliant
there's no question he knows the law
inside and out
but in terms that this person should be
an object of veterans
and this is like one of the great minds
of all time it's a
ridiculous absurdity when you see them
give an opportunity to express
themselves in public
okay so i would say the emperor has some
clothes
you know because i've met i worked at
harvard for quite a long time and many
of the people i met there were
were genuinely estimable and i've worked
in
that's of course okay okay well it's
that's the differentiation here that's
of of such critical importance you know
and
um
pinker's the blank slate is a book
everyone should read i'll i
say that without any asterisks it's an
amazing accomplishment
and you don't go beyond that and say
well look at the structure that gave
rise to that
and i guess it's the tinker is not a fun
that book is not a function of harvard
that book is a function of him
and his ideas and his work and there's
no
no no it's no it's also a function of
harvard
one of the things that i really noticed
about harvard this the psych department
in particular when i was there was that
it was
like this is odd but one of the things
i've noticed
among many academics is contempt for
books
interestingly is that right yes it's far
far more common than you would ever
think
um but that wasn't true at harvard what
if you were a professor there in
psychology and you wrote books
that was valued genuinely valued
the people that i associated with there
and
that that was the bulk of the department
like they were
by and large as genuine an article as i
had come across
and so the the and the institution
actually did now look
i'm not happy with what's happened to
the universities at all
i'm not i think it's it's appalling
it's appalling but when i was
there in the 90s the institution was set
up so that people like pinker
could exist and be rewarded and even
more importantly the institution was set
up at that point to actually benefit the
undergraduates so
the hierarchy of concern was the
undergraduates now you could be cynical
and say well harvard treated its 18 year
olds like
potentially generous baby 40 year old
millionaires
i don't think it was just that it wasn't
just it wasn't just it wasn't
and and after them was the senior
professors the full tenured
so so it was a a a an institution that
had its ducks in order as far as i was
concerned and it was really quite a
privilege to work there as a consequence
and
a tremendous amount of academic and
intellectual freedom within that
structure and that was built into the
whole structure
so it was it was a genuinely
respectable and remarkable institution
and it did a great job of
of finding uh students who were
of incredibly high caliber you know like
in the typical undergraduate harvard
class
a third of the class would be made of
individuals who were as smart as anybody
you'd ever meet
you know so this whole
conservative idea that people who they
don't like
are also dumb is really one of the
stupidest concepts in contemporary
discourse it's a lot easier to train a
smart dog than is to train a dumb one
and many of the people who are putting
over some of these extremely malevolent
nefarious ideas
they're very very bright there's no
question about it but my
and my respect for they weren't just
bright they were they were also
they were also ethically admirable in a
deep sense and you see that with
pinker saying you see that with jonathan
height who's a centrist a moderate
centrist but
you know he's a tough character he
stands up for what he believes in he
makes coherent and cogent arguments and
he's no pushover and i i praise height
very heavily i know you do i know well
that's partly why i'm i'm you know
taking this apart because
i mean our the the anar there's this
element of the
of the of the anarchy philosophy that
that that is
i suppose evident in 4chan as well and
but in your writing that
it seems to me to have the danger of of
producing a premature cynicism and and
oh i wouldn't call it cynicism okay i
mean
i'm a big fan of kamu and kamu albert
camus a french
novelist and philosopher he regarded
cynicism as the enemy
i completely agree i think it's
important to just because
an enemy exists just because malevolent
actors exist even if you don't want to
say it's the harvard graduating class
which i'm not saying
that in no way means that human beings
are inherently evil
or inherently corrupt it just means that
there's a population and you have to
you know just like an infection work
your way around uh whereas
so i think cynicism is a very very very
uh uh just it's i it's the cost of
cynicism on an individual level it
cannot be overstated
it's the worst yes and and one of the
things i
fought for in this book and i fight for
it in when i do podcasts in social media
is there are so many people who think
it's hopeless
and then they give up and then they're
just kind of it becomes their mindset
whereas the point is if there's any
chance that you're gonna
come out ahead you better stand on your
feet and go out swinging
and even if you lose you're gonna go
down at least knowing
i did everything in my power and you're
going to have happiness pride
and self-esteem as a consequence so i i
reject
all forms of cynicism and and if that is
what
i am implying then i'm doing something
wrong
well i'm uh look i'm not saying that my
reading of what you wrote or
or what you're doing is canonical i mean
you're not the only anarchist in the
world
after all and so i'm not going to dump
all of this on you
but um you know
the reason that i have been
concentrating on people's individual
development
i think well apart from the fact that
i'm a psychologist and
and i think there's also less danger in
that in some sense because the
revolution just occurs within you know
and sure
people who don't want your goddamn
revolution aren't aren't forced into it
right um i i guess
by concentrating see you said
that you you implied that i'm not the
corporation and that you're not the
corporation but you see i actually don't
believe that's true
i believe that i am in fact the
corporation and that i me i'm even the
evil corporation and
i'm so tangled up in that world like we
all are that we bear
responsibility for that fact
and so and so i think well what do you
do about that and
it seems to me that you try to get your
act together on a personal level
just to to identify the enemy within
which is the right place to start and
then work outward from that
but your critique is basically a social
critique as far as i can tell that
you're starting with the institutions
themselves
even though it's not the institutions
exactly it's the corruption of the
institutions
i but corruption it makes it seem like
this is something that could be salvaged
whereas in my view these institutions
are inherently
malevolent i know that's your view but
they're no more inherently malevolent
than
individuals are there are plenty of
individuals who are inherently
malevolent
that that's their they go into politics
well not
everyone who goes into politics is
inherently malevolent you know i've met
with
many many politicians and i'll give you
an example because that just means
they're good at passing
no no it doesn't just mean that i i had
a dinner in washington with
a group of democrats and republicans it
was part of an attempt to
you know they never talk to each other
they don't have time
like i would not want the job of an
american cause no they don't
their time is so stop stop no no they're
not they're not they're not running an
ambulance
they're not an er doctor it's just not a
priority for them they have time give me
a break
they just have to just take stuff don't
call back your lobbyist and call that
call
they have are you kidding me you're
telling what people if there's one thing
people in washington have it's time
things go at a glacial pace
look look you you you're making a an
uh an attribution of of corruption to
complex structures and so i'll accept
that but
i don't use the word corruption but go
ahead well pick a word that
pick a word that's more suitable because
i'll i'd be happy to use it if it's more
suitable
malevolent gravity malevolent level
that's it fine
fine power and malevolence okay well
when you're a congressman
and you're tossed into the congress yeah
the
the structure produces such an intense
surround for you that it's extremely
difficult not to just go along with it
especially when you're new and you don't
know what the hell you're doing
so you end up spending a tremendous
amount of your time for example
a disproportionate amount of your time
even though you hate it
in an office that isn't yours in some
warehouse phoning people for money
and that's like half your time and you
think well you don't have to do that
it's like well
you have to because all the others have
to
right okay so in any case they don't end
up talking
across the aisle for for and their time
is very tightly scheduled and
we brought them together to have them
talk
and i wanted to do a bunch of that but
my health collapsed and couldn't do any
more of it but in any case
each of them went around the room and
said why they went into politics
they were these were mostly younger
congress people and
if you would have been there there's two
things that would have impressed you
and surprised you i think one would be
how
common the stories for motivation were
across
the participants regardless of their
party affiliation
and the second would be how believably
and genuinely sincere they were in that
narrative
you wouldn't have walked away with the
pr with the assumption that those people
were any more corrupt than people you
admire and respect that's what makes
them good at being corrupt
because they can pass well but i would
say the same about all of us
i i'm not voting to have people sent
overseas to slaughter innocent human
beings
so i agree with you i don't believe in
voting
well i agree or if you don't vote
i agree with you completely that we
should be skeptical of people and their
motivations
i do not agree that if someone is nice
to their family
i have no doubt that all these
politicians adore their family that they
have genuine concerns that
i'm sure they said they want to make the
world a better place if you are
comfortable
using force to send armed men
to harm innocent people i don't care if
you're nice or have good motivations
you're a bad human being
so i just i just finished a podcast with
jocko willink
okay it released today and he did all
that
like really and it isn't obvious to me
that he's a bad person
in fact jacob's a jacka was in politics
how was he no
he was his soldier and he was a
commander well i mean he made decisions
that
you know he he was a politician in some
sense because
he had to make strategic decisions about
how
policies were going to play out on the
actual battlefield so because he was a
commander
you know there's a political element to
his job because
it's nested inside the democracy and he
is making decisions and
so you know and i i find it very
and it is perplexing to some degree it's
very difficult to walk away from a
conversation with jocko and not think
anything other than that's a really
admirable person
and it does tangle us up in this problem
that you just described which is well
well what about force and what about the
army and what about the police for that
matter but it isn't them you know
it's us again it's the same i'm not a
cop
i'm not a cop it is them i'm not a cop i
would never put my hands
on a peaceful person and try to force
them to come with me in my car
i would never club an old man in the
head simply because he's in a park
i would never force people to be
defenseless in their own home
by enforcing unlawful gun right laws
would you stand up for someone who is
being beat in public
it depends on the context fair enough
look are there circumstances under which
you could imagine doing that
oh i was just gonna say yeah like listen
if it's one guy versus 50 cops me
jumping in is not going to help him
right but if yeah there's absolutely
circumstances i would i would do that
not even a question i've done it too
the circumstances that you would use
force
i don't i don't know well i don't
because i'm a small guy you know i mean
i'm not trying to be glib but in all
seriousness like
uh you know i'm short and i'm small so
if it could be
if there's here's something that has
happened this is not particularly
courageous on my part
if you have two guys who are getting
into it and getting each other's face
and you know they're
that posturing thing where they're about
to fight i have been in between and be
like come on step away
so in that case yes but in terms of
having to use a gun
or club someone to death thankfully i've
never been in a position where i've had
to make that decision
and i do not begrudge people having to
make that decision either it's not an
easy choice there's no
there's no good answers in that
situation but if you take
tax money and as a result of your job
you're going to be harming innocent
people in traumatic ways
i do not agree you should sleep easy at
night
so you know people have
criticized me i suppose for
concentrating on individual development
moral development say well there's all
these
global social problems that are best
addressed at a sociological level and
you know who the hell cares if you clean
up your room when there's systemic
racism and
and i think well if you're going to
address systemic racism
then you better have a clear head while
you do it and if you can't get
the simplest parts of your life let's
say an order well maybe that's what you
should be concentrating on it's not like
i don't think that people should go off
and solve even more complex problems
i mean
there's an element there seems to be an
element of externalization
in the criticism of power structures
that i find
psychologically um counterproductive
you know because i wouldn't look when i
studied the
horrors of the 20th century the
holocaust and the stalinist
horrors and um i always imagined myself
as the perpetrator instead of the victim
you know because the question for me was
how it was that
we could do this that we could do this
to each other that we are
doing it to each other and i mean we and
i do also think the reason i've got away
with my finger shaking moralizing let's
say
to the degree that i have got away with
it is because i do include myself in the
target of
moral reprobates who could use some
improvement and i see the like the
emphasis
i don't see that there's much of a
distinction between
the emphasis that you place on a
broad-scale social critique
um assuming corrupt power is the
what fundamental organizing principle
that large organizations
adopt to organize and the same thing
that leads to identity politics on the
left
i don't think every organization is
inherently built on corruption
i don't think tropicana is built in
corruption okay so okay so how all right
so how do you make the distinction
tropicana doesn't use force and doesn't
try
tropicana says look my our orange juice
is the best
freshly squeezed they get it to your
store at a cheap price at a cheap price
i'm assuming it's
cheap i haven't bought in a long time
you are choose you're free to choose it
or not as you want
your tropicana doesn't try to make you
out to be a bad person if you prefer
apple juice or soda or water
right these other organizations are
playing mind games with people okay so
it's for deceit
it's at least in this part of the use of
the series
and let me speak to something you said
earlier it's different for you and your
i was born in love in western ukraine
uh i was you know we came here when i
was one and a half but i was raised in a
household when we spoke russian
i'm jewish that was one of the reasons i
fought so hard
when i wrote my north korean book and
why i've been talking about north korea
as an issue
because my family was the victim you
know being jewish
under stalin you know during that period
these are really two big bullets that we
dodged
and one of the reasons i went there to
write about and why i talk about it so
constantly
is because there were for the grace of
god i could be a north korean
concentration camp right now
so i think there is i don't know if
there's a um a duty
but certainly if i'm in a position to
you know advocate for people who
are not in a position to really speak
for themselves and these are the people
who
no one disagrees has it the worst no one
disagrees that
whether you're conservative trudeau
trump abide whatever
that we need more liberalism north korea
we need more human rights
we need these people treated with a
certain modicum of decency it's just
unconscionable i'm like i'm gonna do
something about it in my very very
little
uh uh a way so i think it's different
given your and my background
um how you're approaching these horrors
of the past because that was my grandma
and my grandparents well i look
is there a difference i i don't i guess
it isn't clear to me exactly what the
difference is i mean you're well
you're absolutely i wouldn't have been
used to this deceit and power
and sure and and violence though i was i
would not have been in a position to
have been that nazi quite literally
i wouldn't have been a position to be
that uh gpu agent
and one of the reasons i am an anarchist
is i do not feel comfortable tell
forcing another person to live as i see
fit
i just think you know who am i yes well
i think look i i think that's
an admirable moral principle it isn't
obvious to me that the logical
conclusion of that is anarch
is anarchism i suppose that would be my
objection i mean
and i also i do believe that degenerate
power structures exist
and they use deceit and that that's
reprehensible and should be fought
in in every possible way i mean my sense
has been
that there isn't anything more powerful
to fight that than
than spoken truth i agree
and humor well because if they're using
yeah it's very rare
go go ahead talk about humans using
manipulative tactics
in order to further their goal as
opposed to rational discourse as you and
i having we're putting our cards on the
table
if you're using things like deceptive
editing and you know
characterizing things out of context i
am you're not owed a rational fair
response you're not
acting as a decent fair actor so
humor is very useful in this mechanism
because it explodes
not only the particular thing you're
saying but your role as someone who's
worthy of uh courtesy uh respect and
decorum
when i interviewed when i was
interviewed by kathy newman
there was a point where i asked her i
guess why she felt she had the moral
right to offend me
during she was questioning me and it
stopped or the question stopped her and
that was when the person
emerged from the corporate shell let's
say or the ambitious
the corporate shell slash ambitious
persona
because that's what i was talking to
what wasn't a person
and she emerged and she was set back you
know and
i had a second or two to think then
about how i would respond to the fact
that
her mask dropped momentarily and i said
gotcha
and it was a calculated risk it was
supposed to be funny and i do believe
that people responded to it as if it was
funny
and i thought well is this a time is
this a place where i can drop a joke is
this a place where i can say something
and i wasn't thinking about it
strategically precisely i was thinking
about it more in terms of its
hopefully in terms of its ethical
appropriateness
you know and i do believe that humor is
a as a
an immense uh what would you say an
immensely important element of
the search for truth for sp just as play
is
and and and humor is is
there's something about it that's an act
of of self-transcendence too if you can
laugh at yourself right because
you're simultaneously the thing that
needs to be laughed at which is already
behind you if you're laughing at it you
know
you're moving ahead to the better you in
the mere fact of
allowing yourself to satirize yourself
and and so what you're saying is you're
going to be a standard comedian
well i think i have more affinity with
stand-up comedians in some sense than
with any other sort of person
that's true yeah because you are getting
on a stage you're putting on performance
there's going to be moments of uh uh
unexpected twists and terms in in the in
what you're saying and as a function of
that it's going to cause hopefully
things to put together in their brain so
yeah that's
and you know when i'm not very healthy
it's hard to be funny and but it's a lot
it's a
it's a loss like the the best lectures
that i
ever gave have humor in them and and i
mean
hooray for that and you know that's
partly why i toured with dave rubin too
was
to add some levity to what i mean i
learned early on that
even if you're discussing things of
incredible seriousness
you know like genocidal seriousness that
that
if you're if if
let me give you an example because
that's the whole premise of my book dear
reader the north korea book it's
farcical because it's kim jong-il's
autobiography
i went there i read all their literature
and i took the things that these people
are taught and they're
since it's in his voice they're
presented at face value and let me give
you one example of this
kim jong-il is having and how and how
the truth comes in between the lines of
you know
an anecdote so kim jong-il is at this
meeting the dear leader of north korea
and someone's giving
a talk and he's working on papers and
every so often his assistant is asking
him for
your input and the speaker stops and kim
jong-il goes
why are you stopping goes well you know
dear leader you're working on those
papers you've got your assistant he goes
no
no i could do all these three things at
once and they said from that point on
people regarded kim jong-il as looking
at time as not a plane
but a cube and that he had the ability
to shrink
time and my friend said to me do they
mean multitasking
and they did and according to north
korean propaganda kim jong-il
is the only person in north korea who
knows how to multitask and when you have
these
anecdotes put forth in this manner
you realize how removed from reality
it's not that he's a magical figure it's
just like something that's just
absolutely banal
is being presented as some kind of major
historical accomplishment so
humor to you know is and another example
there was an amusement park and
one of the things how north korea claims
that they're different from other
totalitarian states is they have
something called field guidance
whenever you read the newspaper they
have they have field field guidance
fields guidance yes so whenever you read
their newspapers is whoever the current
leader is he's at the bottle factory
he's at the munitions plant
he's at the farm he's giving them
guidance on how to make these things
better and as a consequence of this the
implication is everyone north korea is
incompetent other than the leader so
you better have him in place but there
was one story that i include in the book
where there's an amusement park and it
starts lightly raining
and kim jong-il insists on riding all
the rides twice
to make sure they're safe for the
children the elderly and everyone on the
platform
the dignitaries are all crying at his
courage and it's like the guy's taking a
roller coaster ride
like you're regarding him as the kind of
like the planting the flag in iwo jima
but he's on this this roller coaster so
this kind of contrast between
something that is uh you know fun and
for kids and silly
but being presented as this great
courageous moment and this guy's a hero
that absurd distance is what drives a
lot of the narrative
did you see the strange death of stalin
oh that book is as close to dear reader
uh the last days of stalin you mean the
movie yeah the the
yeah did i get the title wrong you said
strange death i think it's last days
i thought it's the last days of stalin
it's by anthony yanuchi who made veep as
well
no and i was it's the it's the death of
stella and we're both
wrong we're both wrong that's probably
characterizes our whole conversation
i was so glad that book came out after
dear reader
because it's exactly the same tone as i
used to the point where i would be
accused of stealing that movie and
that's just just one moment just
how they use humor to present stalin's
air of terror
stalin has a stroke he's dying he's in
his own urine in his
room and the two guards are out there
and they hear this
noise inside the bedroom and one that
goes should we go in there and look and
the other guy goes should we shut the
[ __ ] up
so but that's the thing it's like be
quiet head down
stalin at this point obviously would
genuinely want your assistance and we
want your help
but because yeah but it's a little too
late for that
but maybe it wasn't they didn't know
that right right but because these rules
are in place
yeah these rules are in place the focus
is always on fear
and not speaking out of turn even if
ostensibly it could have saved the
greatest man in the world
you know so okay so when i read your
book and when i looked at
the memes that these young guys were
generating years ago you know
and that me too and and then considered
the role of satire and all of that
now i'm just remembering what i told my
kids when i was raising them because we
i encouraged my kids to be funny that
was very highly valued in our household
to be witty and witty and funny
is really hard because you have to push
right to the edge
yep yep and not go over and the closer
you get to the edge and not
without going over the funnier you are
the more daring you are because in part
you
you show your sophisticated mastery
you're so such a sophisticated master of
the social dynamic
that you can go right to the edge of
breaking a rule
and not break it or maybe you can break
it
just enough to show that it should be
broken in exactly that manner
right and then that's really witty
that's really funny and so there's no
doubt that that ability to be
funny to be satirical to be witty is a a
potent manifestation of the truth
but then you know with my kids i was
also
watching them constantly you know you
can get sibling rivalries that that go
completely out of control
in a household and so i'd watch them
teasing each other
and playing with each other and and
would intervene and say look you know
that's not funny anymore that's not a
game
that's where it starts to deteriorate
into tyranny or deteriorates into a
power game
it's like stay on the right side of
funny you're you're pretending that
you're being funny but
really you're being mean okay and we
also see this with racist humor
a lot of times a joke we have a racial
element and it's humorous
but a lot of times someone who's being a
racist is just putting up feelers
by saying okay you've accepted this joke
can i drop the mask and
you could just engage in pure hate so
yeah it's even worse
right because you're using something
that really is a tool for the good
let's say humor and you're perverting it
so that you're
masking something awful so that's
analogous in some sense to this
corporate malfeasance that you were
discussing
and so i guess in the the sense i get
when looking at
the the the irreverence of these young
guys
essentially on 4chan i think just bloody
well make sure you stay on the right
side of funny
and there's always doubt in that and
maybe there has to be but
but but it's still the right moral
imperative it's like go ahead with your
humor man but like watch your tongue
like watch your tongue it's also the
idea of claptor
where you had all these comedians going
after trump or whoever and the audience
instead of laughing which is a visceral
reaction
would applaud and it's like they're not
they don't think you're funny they're
agreeing with you it's it's kind of like
people whose favorite kind of music is
like religious music it's like
you don't necessarily which a lot of
which is very good a lot of christian
rock is very good don't get me wrong
they're very talented people
but do you like this song because you
like the beat do you like how it makes
you feel
or do you like this song because you
happen to agree with the person
these are entirely different phenomena
yes well there has to be an element of
surprise and humor right
yes oh yes and that and that that also
accounts for that
um uh spontaneous laughter which is an
indication that the
arrow hit its mark right that the target
is being specified properly and
precisely and it really is a form of art
to do that
and so well then i think
i always had mixed feelings about the
the the
satirists in on 4chan for exactly that
reason it's like
well are you really watching what you're
saying carefully enough like hurray for
your humor
hurray for your courage all of that but
this is like the stephen pinker's
in any population you're going to have a
small percentage who rise above who are
quality and
and that um whatever it is at its best
and the vast majority of people bring
nothing to the table and then there's
plenty of people who actually use
that mechanism to make things much worse
right well and that's interesting as
well because it also like i always think
well wouldn't it be great if there were
only good restaurants
and then i think well wait a second how
many bad restaurants do there have to be
in order for there to be one
restaurant and the answer isn't zero
yeah yeah there's definitely some
because people have to practice and they
have to make mistakes and they have to
learn and
well right and so you look at 4chan too
and you can think well how much
wretched humorless racist noise do you
have to tolerate in order to generate
something of true value and the answer
to that is i think
two one is we don't know that's the
first answer and so beware of
clamping down on it too precipitously
but the second is
maybe that's also something that each of
the people who are
involved in that kind of activity should
should be
attending to you know within the
confines of their own soul
so to speak i mean they're anonymous and
it's evanescent but that doesn't mean
that
you bear no moral responsibility for
what you're saying
yes and i think cruelty for the sake of
cruelty
is really a sign of weakness it's the
kid pulling
the wings off of a bug or like you know
putting tin cans on a cat's tail
uh it's a way for people to just feel
some modicum of power over another human
being
but that's a very parasitic way of
looking at things uh and using this
other person as a means to an
end and this person might not be a great
person but really what are you
accomplishing
you're just both miserable now uh that
there's there needs to be in my view
a joyousness to what you're trying to do
and i certainly hope that permeates my
work and my uh
uh output
that's a good place to stop thank you
sir
thank you very much i hope you enjoyed
this
it so far so good
[Laughter]
such an honor thank you can i ask you
what do you have to bounce right now or
do you have time for one question i have
time for a question uh in your absence
i've been kind of taking a lot of young
men under my wing
and kind of mentoring them i saved one
kid's life when he reached out to me he
was suicidal and now he's just kind of
has bad days
which yes that's that's all you need
that's something yeah like yeah that bad
days if you're not a threat to your life
whatever
what advice would you have to me or to
your past self when this started
happening for you
uh because i'm very scared of saying the
wrong thing and making things worse
you there's no way you can pay too much
attention
okay like ignorant attention
watch the person and you do that when
you're in
in conversation you know yeah paying
attention
more attention and you can't offer
advice in some sense you have to listen
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah like it's still
hard but if you pay attention like if
you pay attention
your your good habits will take over and
and you'll
walk down the right course okay humility
and attention
that's good humility and attention as
i'm sure you've seen it's amazing how
many young people
just want someone to listen to them and
they it's it's just
have some that they respect and once
that happens they feel so validated yeah
well they really just want you to
say something that they're doing that's
good to someone
yes and have it be recognized as good
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's superb advice
thank you so much it was such an honor
jordan
okay take care thanks michael
[Music]
you